so ich will auch noch meine fragen
loswerden und deswegen verloren die mich
gerade sehen und hallo an lena
du weißt nichts bereuen hast du schon
mal was dort
wenn ich dir jetzt sagen würde dass du
dich an jeden ort der welt hin
teleportieren könntest würdest du dich
dann jetzt befinden und warum
ich würde jetzt in singapur sein und mir
ein hello kitty case für mein handy
kaufen
was würdest du den menschen man kann
sagen die einfach ihr handy zücken und
ich fühlen mode fotografieren ohne dass
ich vor gefragt
ich finde dass das land ein ziemlich
respekt nur so sache ist ich mache sehr
gerne fotos wenn man mich vorher fragt
dann finde ich das eine echt tolle sache
aber
einfach so fotos und filme machen finde
ich ziemlich respektlos und
vielleicht sollte man vorher mal
überlegen ob man es dann selber auch
gerne wollen würde also ob sie das gut
finden wenn ich
verlieren zählen würde hallo
in deutschland zeigen hier jetzt auch
bekannte regisseure und anderem til
schweiger ihre aufmerksamkeit wie sieht
deine zukunft als schauspielerin aus
also im moment das video zieht mich ein
bisschen runter
redete tief und so ernst
darum den soja als
transportiert auch mal ernst ich hab
jetzt im moment konzentriere ich mich
auf die musik
und danach
wollen wir mal sehen
aber gute fragen hast du gestellt